>>> A FEDERAL JUDGE REJECTED THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BID TO
CONTINUE WITH THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CONTENT
OF THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTEDS
SEIZED AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT JUDGE HAS ALSO APPOINTED A
SPECIAL MASTER TO REVIEW THE
DOCUMENTS AND SET A NOVEMBER
30th DEADLINE TO COMPLETE THE
REVIEW.
WITH ME IS THE PUBLISHER OF THE
BLOG LAW FAIR, DAVID PRIEST.
AS PART OF THIS RULING JUDGE
CANNON SAID THAT SHE DOESN'T
ACCEPT THE GOVERNMENT'S ARGUMENT
THAT LOOK, THESE WERE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, THEREFORE, DONALD
TRUMP DOESN'T HAVE ANY RIGHT TO
HOLD ONTO THEM.
AND WHAT JUDGE CANNON WROTE
HERE, I WANT TO READ THIS.
SHE SAID THE COURT DOES NOT FIND
IT APPROPRIATE TO ACCEPT THE
GOVERNMENT'S CONCLUSION ON THESE
IMPORTANT AND DISPUTED ISSUES
WITHOUT FURTHER REVIEW BY A
NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY.
DISPUTED ISSUES, WOULD SEEM TO
SUGGEST THAT SHE CONSIDERS IT A
DISPUTED ISSUE WHETHER THESE
WERE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
>> TO BE CLEAR, TRUMP'S LEGAL
TEAM DID NOT DISPUTE SOME OF
THOSE CORE FACTS.
THEY DID NOT ASSERT THESE WERE
DECLASSIFIED OR UNCLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
SO THE JUDGE IS CREATING THE
DISPUTE SAYING THE GOVERNMENT IS
ASSERTING THESE ARE CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS, WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
ACTUAL DOCUMENTS BECAUSE THAT'S
THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION THEY
DON'T WANT TO SHOW TO THE PUBLIC
AND OUR ADVERSARIES, BUT
PRESUMABLY THESE ARE TOP SECRET,
SECRET, AND CONFIDENTIAL
DOCUMENTS.
SHE IS SAYING I DON'T TRUST YOU
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
CLASSIFIED.
WHO DO I TRUST?
A SPECIAL MASTER WHO'S GOING TO
DETERMINE, MORE THAN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, WHAT IS
CLASSIFIED AND ISN'T.
IT'S A SILLY RULING.
I HATE TO USE THAT ADJECTIVE
BECAUSE IT HAS AN IMPACT ON
NATIONAL SECURITY.
BUT THE RULING ITSELF IS
NON
NONSENSE.
>> IN THE SUBPOENA, THE LANGUAGE
IS MARKED AS CLASSIFIED.
IN A WAY, LEGALLY IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
IT ONLY MATTERS THEY WERE MARKED
AS CLASSIFIED.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT WOULD
BE DISPUTED.
WHAT COULD THE DISPUTE BE?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ONE.
I THINK IT WAS AN EXCUSE TO
DELAY THE PROCESS.
THE JUDGE WANTED TO DELAY THE
PROCESS, THAT WAS CLEAR FROM THE
BEGINNING AND SHE'S LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING TO DO TO DO THAT.
THIS IS A WEAK ONE TO GRAB ONTO.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HOLD UP ON
APPEAL, IF IT GOES TO THAT,
WHICH I EXPECT IT WILL BECAUSE
THERE'S NO PRECEDENT FOR THIS,
FOR A JUDGE ASSERTING SOMETHING
MIGHT NOT BE CLASSIFIED.
THERE ARE PEOPLE PROSECUTED IN
CASES OF MISHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WHO WOULD LOVE TO GO
BEFORE A JUDGE WHO DID NOT HAVE
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS SAYING
THESE ARE NOT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS BUT THE JUDGE SAYS
MAYBE THAWEY'RE NOT CLASSIFIED,
LET'S NOT WORRY ABOUT IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> AND IN NO COURT HAS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF DONALD TRUMP
SAID THAT DONALD TRUMP
DECLASSIFIED THE DOCUMENTS.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED IN A
COURTROOM OR A DOCUMENT.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY, IT
CARRIES MORE WEIGHT IF IT'S IN A
DOCUMENT THAN SAID OUT LOUD IN A
POLITICAL SETTING.
DONALD TRUMP DID AN INTERVIEW
WITH HUGH HEWITT YESTERDAY.
LISTEN.
>> MR. PATEL SAID HE WITNESSED
YOU GIVING VERBAL ORDERS TO
DECLASSIFY THE DOCUMENTS THAT
ENDED UP ON MAR-A-LAGO.
DO YOU REMEMBER MAKING THOSE
ORDERS?
>> YES.
NOT ONLY THAT, I HAVE THE
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO DECLASSIFY.
A PRESIDENT HAS THAT ABSOLUTE
RIGHT AND A LOT OF PEOPLE AREN'T
EVEN CHALLENGING THAT ANYMORE.
>> DOES ANYONE CHALLENGE A
SITTING PRESIDENT HAS A RIGHT TO
DECLASSIFY?
>> NO.
>> THAT THE A MOOT ISSUE BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A FORMER
PRESIDENT HERE.
HE SAYS THAT KASH PATEL
WITNESSED HIM DECLASSIFYING AND
OTHERS DID TOO.
BUT THE LAWYERS, THEY'RE NOT
MAKING THAT CASE IN COURT, ARE
THEY?
>> NO.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T EXECUTE THE
PROCESS.
SAY HYPOTHETICALLY THE PRESIDENT
IN THE PRESENCE OF KASH PATEL
AND A FEW OTHER PEOPLE DID SAY I
WANT TO DECLASSIFY EVERYTHING.
GREAT.
HE CAN SAY THAT.
IF NOBODY EXECUTED THAT, TOLD
THE AGENCY ORIGINAL NATING THE
INFORMATION THIS WAS DECL
DECLASSIFIED THERE'S STILL
DOCUMENTS OUT THERE THAT ARE
STILL CLASSIFIED AND YOU CAN'T
RETROACTIVELY DO IT.
A FORMER PRESIDENT CAN'T SAY I
MEANT TO PUT IN THE PROCESS TO
DECLASSIFY THESE.
OTHERWISE EVERY PRESIDENT UPON
LEAVING OFFICE WOULD BE ABLE TO
SAY THAT HE OR SHE DID X, Y, Z,
INCLUDING CLASSIFICATION OR
DECLASSIFICATION SYSTEMS AND
RUIN THE SYSTEM.
>> I WANT TO NOTE THAT OTHERS,
INCLUDING ME, HAVE TALKED TO
FORMER TRUMP OFFICIALS NONE OF
WHOM SAID THEY HEARD A BLANKET
DECLASSIFICATION.
AND MANY PEOPLE USE LANGUAGE
THAT SUCH A NOTION IS ABSURD.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
JOINING ME CNN LEGAL ANALYST
JOEY JACKSON AND LEGAL ANALYST
JENNIFER ROGERS.
LET ME START WITH YOU, JEN.
YOUR TAKE ON THIS ASPECT OF THE
RULING?
NO STAY.
>> YEAH, THIS IS A TERRIBLE
OPINION.
DOJ GAVE HER AN OFFRAFR-RAMP FO
THIS.
SAYING LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WHICH THERE
IS NO LEGAL JUSTIFICATION FOR
LETTING TRUMP HAVE THOSE BACK,
NO PRIVILEGES, NOTHING.
SHE STILL SAID NO.
YOU STILL HAVE TO STOP.
THEY PUT IN AN AFFIDAVIT
EXPLAINING THE HARM IF THEY HAD
TO STOP REVIEWING THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THERE'S NO CONTRARY FACTS.
JUDGES ARE SUPPOSED TO DECIDE ON
THE FACTS.
THE EVIDENCE IS THE AFFIDAVIT.
TRUMP'S TEAMS PUT IN NO
AFFIDAVIT.
SHE DOESN'T CONTEST ANY FACTS
BUT JUST SAYS I'M NOT CONVINCED.
AT THE END OF HER OPINION SHE
TELLS US WHY, YOU HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE CONTEXT AND THE
CONTEXT IS IT IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND THAT GOVERNS
EVERYTHING FOR HER.
>> WHAT SHE DOES SAY IS SAY THE
ONLY THING I'M SAYING YOU CAN'T
DO IS USE THE CONTENT OF THESE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
YOU CAN'T READ OUT LOUD THE
DOCUMENTS TO WITNESSES YOU
QUESTION.
YOU CAN'T PUT THE CONTENT OF THE
DOCUMENTS BEFORE THE GRAND JURY
BUT YOU CAN PUT THE FACT THEY
EXIST BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
YOU CAN INVESTIGATE HOW THE
DOCUMENTS GOT TO A CERTAIN
PLACE.
YOU CAN TALK TO WITNESSES IN
GENERAL ABOUT THE FACT OF THE
DOCUMENT.
SO CAN'T AN INVESTIGATION
CONTINUE?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO SPLIT HAIRS LIKE THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE PRESENTING ANYTHING
TO A GRAND JURY, YOU WANT
INFORMATION.
YOU WANT THAT INFORMATION TO BE
RELIABLE.
YOU WANT QUESTIONS THAT GRAND
JURORS POTENTIALLY HAVE TO BE
ANSWERED TO THEIR SATISFACTION.
THOSE ARE THE ONES ACTUALLY
ISSUING THE INDICTMENT.
MY ONLY ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO
DISAGREEING WITH JEN A LITTLE
BIT IS IT'S ABOUT TRUST FOR ME
AND THE GOVERNMENT.
I'M A DEFENSE ATTORNEY.
AS A DEFENSE ATTORNEY I LOOK TO
JUDGES, GENERALLY, OKAY,
GENERALLY SUPPORT THE
PROSECUTION'S POINT OF VIEW.
WHAT THE PROSECUTION WANTS THE
PROSECUTION GETS.
WE BEG FOR THINGS IN COURT.
SIT DOWN, MR. JACKSON, MAYBE
TOMORROW.
I THINK IT'S A SENSE OF VALUE
AND BELIEF THAT WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS DOING IS ACCURATE.
YOU CAN'T TAKE REPRESENTATIONS
OF WHAT A PROSECUTOR GIVES YOU
IN COURT WHAT THE INFORMATION
IS.
WHAT'S THE HARM IN HAVING A
NEUTRAL PARTY SIT AND EVALUATE
THE INFORMATION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVE IT OR
NOT DO NOT AGREE AND SUPPORT
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT DOES.
I THINK THIS PAUSE, AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WHATEVER HAPPENS IN
THIS INVESTIGATION, YOU'RE GOING
TO SAY YOU HAD A NEUTRAL THIRD
PARTY EVALUATE, PUT IT ON PAUSE,
NOW WE CAN TRUST IT AND LET'S GO
AGAIN.
>> I DETECTED A HEAD NOD THERE.
>> IT'S BASED UPON NOTHING, SHE
HAS LEGAL ANALYSIS FROM DOJ WHY
THERE IS NO LEGAL BASIS TO GIVE
IT TO TRUMP.
SHE HAS NOTHING FROM TRUMP AND
SHE DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY.
>> I GET THAT.
>> THERE'S NO LEGAL BASIS.
>> MY ONLY ISSUE IS, I THINK AT
THE END OF THE DAY, THERE'S SO
MUCH POLITICAL SPIN ON THIS.
EVERYBODY IS OUT THERE, YOU KNOW
WHAT, THIS IS A POLITICAL HIT
JOB ON THE PRESIDENT, ET CETERA.
YOU LOOK AT THE DOCUMENTS, PAUSE
THE INVESTIGATION, NO RUSH.
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT JUDGE DEARIE
DOES, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN TOLD TO
PRIORITIZE THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
IT COULD BE A QUICK PROCESS ON
THOSE ALONE.
YOU CAN SEE JUDGE DEARIE SAYING,
GO AHEAD.
>> EXCEPT THEN WHAT DOES JUDGE
CANNON DO?
BECAUSE TRUMP'S TEAM WILL COME
BACK, JUDGE DEARIE GOT THIS
WRONG, HELP US FIX THIS, WHAT
DOES SHE DO?
>> THAT'S A FASCINATING QUESTION
GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR HELPING ME
UNDERSTAND THIS.